[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du journal de la rédaction tout
de suite les titres en images de ce
mardi 11 avril 2017 a plus que douze
jours avant le premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle un scrutin
très ouvert le député yvelinois benoît
hamon espère encore pouvoir inverser la
tendance
françois pervis à la conquête de
nouveaux titres mondiaux le cycliste ini
montant est à hong kong jusqu'à dimanche
avec de fortes ambitions et puis les
beaux jours également synonyme de retour
de certains fruits et légumes que
faut-il manger en ce moment détour par
le marché le mot repas au cours de cette
édition
je vous demande de mme élire un
président de la république le député des
yvelines candidat à l'élection
présidentielle a décidé de s'adresser
aujourd'hui aux français à travers une
lettre édité à neuf millions
d'exemplaires benoît hamon qu'ils
annoncent comme les dix autres candidats
ses dernières forces dans la bataille à
12 jours seulement du premier tour mais
pour le socialiste l'enjeu est
particulièrement important stopper son
effondrement dans les sondages lui qui
aujourd'hui est passé sous la barre
symbolique des 10%
dans son courrier il évoque les
difficultés ces dernières semaines
annonce ébranlé aucune de mes
convictions elles les ont confirmés
écrit-il
comme une réponse aux récentes rumeurs
de retrait de sa part en faveur de
jean-luc mélenchon petite satisfaction
néanmoins aujourd'hui on vient
d'apprendre qu'il intégrera tout comme
emmanuel macron la cuvée 2010 8 du
dictionnaire le robert et luxe illustré
publié le 15 juin ainsi que la version
du bric du robert des noms propres
on passe à l'actualité plus local avec
elle et les travaux qui se poursuivent à
montigny le bretonneux sur le boulevard
kessel situé entre l'avenue nicolas à
bout et le rond point de la route à
guyancourt
cette fois ci le chantier de grande
envergure a débuté en septembre dernier
montant total des travaux pour
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
plus de trois millions d'euros trottoirs
chaussée arrêt de mu places de
stationnement c'est un lifting complet
qui s'opèrent en ce moment et encore
pour plusieurs mois jusqu'en 2018 en
éclairage qui est relativement
énergivores qui est vieux car plus de 35
ans il est d'origine
donc c'est également l'occasion de
reprendre tout l'éclairage en mettant
des membres à led qui seront modulables
également que 22h30 et et 6 heures du
matin il ya une baisse d'intensité
d'environ 30 % avec un éclairage donc
amplement suffisant pour cheminement
nocturne très sécurisé maire en faisant
des économies très substantiel au niveau
de la consommation électrique
avec l'arrivée du printemps le retour du
soleil a rien de mieux que de faire un
tour du côté des marchés pour acheter
des produits de saison 33 % des français
estiment que les légumes et les fruits
ont un meilleur goût quand ils sont de
saison si l'on en croit un récent
sondage ipsos bon recevant savoir un
petit peu plus nous sommes rendus au
marché et de maurepas haussmann vendeurs
des nicolas landry l'arrivée du
printemps est aussi synonyme du retour
de certains fruits et légumes tels que
des épinards les carottes l'avocat ou
encore le citron pour les consommateurs
car pente les allées du marché de
maurepas
c'est important de consommer les
produits de saison j'ai acheté des
épinards du potiron du show call j'adore
ça c'est plein de vitamine c est
délicieux et qu'est-ce que j'ai pris
d'autres une grande salade et les
carottes les choix donc c'est le
maraîcher déjà pourquoi parce que c'est
une filière courte et essentiellement du
bio et après je suis les saisons et lui
aussi
grosso modo quoi un sondage ipsos
indique que 36 % des français
choisissent leurs fruits et légumes en
fonction de la saison
selon cette même étude il serait 56% à
faire confiance aux conseils de leurs
maraîchers selon leur menu des fois ils
nous demandent genre la pomme de terre
on a deux variétés de pommes de terre on
à la pomme de terre charlotte une pomme
de terre assez ferme c'est plus pour
faire sauter
à l'eau etc et nous avons aussi la pomme
de terre mona lisa il est plus une femme
d'état peut-il se défait pour la purée
l'a soufflé fit donc on fait les clients
en fonction de ce qui va les manger
et pour les gourmands sachez que la
fraise devrait faire son grand retour
sur les étals à partir du mois de mai et
surtout n'oubliez pas de manger cinq
fruits et légumes par jour
nous parlons high tech à présent
économie également vous avez pu voir
leurs caméras pendant la quinzaine de
roland garros ou encore sur l'arrivée du
tour de france ils ont également réalisé
plusieurs plans pour le film
transformers un cas la société acs
france spécialiste dans la prise de vue
aérienne est en mouvement a ouvert les
portes de son entreprise pour le grand
public du côté de buc
l'occasion de découvrir les dernières
innovations de cette la société michael
et demi d'euros alors comment ça
fonctionne donc il ya une radiocommande
en fait qui permet d'aller à droite ou à
gauche
et puis une gâchette qui permet d'aller
en avant et en arrière donc il ya un
deuxième opérateur qui s'occupe de faire
tourner la caméra à 360 degrés dans les
trois axes de l'espace pour cadrer le
sujet battu raymond ne travaille pas sur
un projet top secret de la nasa mais
chez acs france le spécialiste français
de la prise de vue aérienne est en
mouvement
aujourd'hui ce club de drones présente
au public le dernier né de l'entreprise
un buggy avec un système de caméra trois
axes qui peut aller jusqu'à 120 km heure
c'est utilisé pour tout ce qui est filmé
de course à pied ou de voitures ou des
plans assez dynamique et c'est aussi
utilisé dans le sport pour les suivis de
des suivis de d'athlètes dans l'effort
ou
ce genre de mouvement toujours des
mouvements en action assez rapide
cette innovation rejoint la caverne
d'ali baba technologiques de
l'entreprise le siège est implanté à
bucca en stock des dizaines de drones
des voitures équipées de caméras et des
grues le public présent ce jeudi 6 avril
pendant ces journées portes ouvertes a
été plongé dans un film de science
fiction et y'a vraiment que du matériel
un peu spécifique et tout ne s'est pas d
du matériel qu'on a l'habitude de voir
tous les jours
[Musique]
forcément un côté avant gardiste qui
plaît au monde audiovisuel français et
international l'entreprise enregistré
l'année dernière un chiffre d'affaires
compris entre 2,5 et 3 millions d'euros
et vient de collaborer avec des grosses
productions hollywoodiennes comme
transformers 1 qui sortira en juin
prochain
on a un savoir-faire de 20 ans une
technologique et technologies de pointe
on essaie aujourd'hui d'investir dans du
matériel qui fonctionne on peut comparer
avec quelque chose qui est vraiment bien
aboutie pour observer en direct ce
matériel dernier cri il faudra patienter
jusqu'à former la quinzaine du tournoi
de tennis roland garros
l'un des plus anciens partenaires de la
structure cette histoire dure depuis
2002 chaque mardi dans le journal nous
vous proposons de découvrir celles et
ceux qui font l'actualité dans les
yvelines aujourd'hui rencontre avec la
présidente du tribunal administratif de
versailles nathalie macias portrait
préparé par nicolas landry article après
article attali macias consulte le code
de justice administrative
un outil de travail quotidien pour la
présidente du tribunal administratif de
versailles
on sait pas tout donc on a toujours
besoin de vérifier les questions de
compétence territoriale des questions
procédure à 55 ans il vient de prendre
la tête de la juridiction administrative
à versailles une carrière de magistrate
qui se dessine après son bac littéraire
lorsqu'elle rentre à l'institut
politique de paris on se cultivait et
j'avais l'impression d'apprendre ce que
tout le monde a envie de savoir c'est à
dire
le droit l'économie mais aussi la vie
politique
après sciences po nathalie macias
intègre l'école nationale de
l'administration à seulement 22 ans
promotion denis diderot
c'est une partie de la promo seul ans
que je suis là on était allé on avait
été reçue à la préfecture de la seine et
marne par le préfet de la seine et marne
de l'époque avec le directeur de l'école
qu'ils étaient simon aura dès son entrée
à des là elle est en stage première
expérience huit mois à la préfecture de
la nièvre le monde de l'administration
des préfectures le monde de la province
le fait de vivre seul
ça c'était l'intérêt de la scolarité de
l'ena c'était les stages qui tout d'un
coup mettait la jeune étudiante que
j'étais en situation de travail
attiré par le contentieux administratif
nathalie macias s'oriente vers une
carrière dans la magistrature
administrative elle trouve sa vocation à
travers l'utilité publique
on est là à la fois pour servir
l'intérêt général
et puis aussi protéger les intérêts
particuliers et protégé l'administration
contre elle même fille sortie de l'ena
elle est affectée au tribunal
administratif de lille elle a occupé des
postes de rapporteur public et de
président de chambre à paris maulin et
nantes
elle devient chef de juridiction à
poitiers en 2012 avant de rejoindre en
septembre dernier
versailles sous son autorité 43
magistrats et 56 agents de greffe
mon travail est essentielle c'est un
travail d'encadrement et d'organisation
j'ai toujours une activité
juridictionnelle puisque je vais
présider chacune des chambres
à tour de rôle récemment deux affaires
traitées par le tribunal administratif
de versailles ont marqué la présidente
la requête a été déposée par salle
abdeslam qui est détenu à la maison
d'arrêt de fleury mérogis et qui
contestait sa mise sous vidéo
surveillance 24 heures sur 24
et puis nous avons eu aussi une affaire
très douloureuse qui est celle de
l'inhumation de abala qui est l'assassin
des deux policiers de magnanville au
mois de juin 2016 dossier après dossier
nathalie macias poursuit son activité au
service de la protection de
l'administration et des administrés du
sport et en cyclisme sur piste françois
pervis le pistard neuf à l'équipe de
france six fois champion du monde qui
disputera les championnats du monde à
hong kong et dès demain et jusqu'à
dimanche et ligne montrent un qui
s'entraîne presque tous les jours sur la
piste du vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines a deux très grosses
ambitions pour cette compétition il va
disputer la vitesse par équipes la
vitesse individuelle le kilomètre et le
keirin
le sportif de 32 ans serait également un
relais pour la jeune génération
tricolore
c'est ce qu'il a expliqué au micro de
michael mino c'est vrai que maintenant
je fais partie des meubles comme on dit
je suis le plus ancien de l'équipe de
france depuis déjà quelques années
maintenant il ya une nouvelle génération
qui arrive après les jeux de rio
c'est à moi de le rapporter les petites
ficelles du métier leur donner des
conseils pour éviter les très grosses
erreurs après c'est important qu'ils
apprennent de même qu'ils suivent pas
exactement un mot pour mot ce que je
leur dis où le chemin comme moi j'ai
pris il faut qu'ils trouvent leur propre
chemin leur propre façon de faire ce
sport toujours pour terminer ce journal
ce sera une grande première en novembre
prochain le rallye des gazelles à un
raid d'ordinaire 100% féminin créé en
1990 va s'ouvrir aux hommes nous avons
donc décidé de suivre un couple
yvelinois qui s'engagent dans l'aventuré
un couple dans la vie une passion
commune le mythique rallye des gazelles
ces deux habitants de
vélizy-villacoublay vont participer
ensemble à la première édition de ce
raid
ouverte aux hommes on a toujours eu
cette envie de partir et partager notre
envie de conduire à 4-4 sur des pistes
on aime les grands espaces on aime le
maroc
un baptême du feu pour pascal burg le
sportif est partie de l'organisation
depuis 15 ans mais n'a jamais pris le
départ de l'épreuve
al'inverse sa femme fabienne la langue
est une gazelle chevronné a déjà
participé à quatre éditions donc le
rallye il approche le connaît il sait ce
que c'est mais je dirais en théorie par
rapport aux participants et alors le
voir de l'extérieur c'est une chose et
le voir de l'intérieur c'est autre chose
et c'est vraiment quelque chose de
fabuleux c'est une très belle aventure
et ça valait le coup qu'on le partage
tous les deux dans le 4 4 les rôles sont
déjà répartis pascal burg restera le
volant à sa faim plan toute la durée de
l'épreuve pour se concentrer sur
l'orientation interdiction d'utiliser un
gps seuls des cartes en noir et blanc
datant des années 60 et la boussole sont
autorisés ce qui me plaît dans la
navigation c'est toute la partie c'est
tout à fait moi en fait
intellectuel donc la réflexion le choix
la stratégie donc j'en sais ce que je
vais travailler puisque en temps normal
tu plutôt volant d'un véhicule un des 4
4 mais là je vais me mettre à côté
je vais essayer de guide et fabienne du
mieux que je puisse donc c'est vraiment
cette partie là khimki matière et c'est
vraiment mon gros de challenge pour être
prêt à 100% le jour j les deux
aventuriers pratique le hors piste
régulièrement dans les forêts de la
région parisienne avec leurs véhicules
une première approche de la compétition
sans l'étude maintenant moi je travaille
mes cartes fabienne de temps en temps
dès qu'on peut on roule roule au volant
du véhicule pour ne rien perdre et
surtout apprivoiser on va dire le
véhicule ce duo encore quelques mois
pour dompter ce 4 4 le gaz et les
domaines est programmée du 4 au 11
novembre dans le désert marocain
c'est la fin de ce journal en deux vous
mercredi avec nicolas kirillovitch pour
une nouvelle édition très belle soirée
sur notre antenne
[Musique]